fill in the blank time patrick mahomes
clapping back at tom brady is what
shireen
i'm gonna go with brazen might because i
do think it's brazen even in a joking
manner because we know tom brady never
forgets anything and he will bring that
up at some point i guarantee you
this year he's gonna bring that up what
patrick mahomes tweeted so it may be all
in fun but brady never forgets he's got
a long memory mike
it it is dangerous it really is somebody
pointed out to me yesterday in the
aftermath of our discussions about
trevor lawrence and the fact that he
doesn't have a chip on his shoulder the
reality is nothing's happened to him to
have a chip on his shoulder yet maybe
he'll get one in that tom vs time
facebook live series from a few years
ago there was a point where brady said
if you want to come get me you're going
to have to be willing to devote your
life to it because i have
and
even though it's impossible for him to
devote more of his life to it
yes this will this he will find a way
to to make make it as impossible as it
can be for patrick mahomes to catch him
and that means getting to number eight
maybe getting to number nine before he
walks away for good all right the draft
rumor slash report out there that might
have legs is what shireen
well i think i'm going to go with new
england trading up to take a quarterback
bill belichick has never drafted a
quarterback in the top 60 and i know
people appointed that but hey until this
year he never spent a ton of money in
free agency either and he did that right
he wants to create a winner a long time
winner prove he can do it without tom
brady the best way to do that is to find
a quarterback they don't have that guy
on their roster mike to do what tom
brady did over a lengthy period of time
20 years
or more and so i think we could see a
trade up for him to drive to quarterback
perhaps with the carolina panthers at
number eight although we also know that
the panthers may want to quarterback two
even though they have sam darnold i
doubt they do but that might be a prime
position
for the patriots to move up to number
eight overall and give up some
some draft capital to go up and get the
guy who can who can be the next tom
brady frankly
my gut feeling continues to be that bill
belichick loves cam newton and wants to
see how far newton can take the team and
would rather use that draft capital on
guys who can win now they're in a
definite win now mode not draft a guy
and and put him on ice for a year or so
and wait and see what happens but we'll
see hey belichick is not going to tell
us ahead of time what he's going to do
that's for damn sure not that anyone is
but the last one who would is belichick
i'm going to say the dolphins trading
down from six that won't surprise me at
all the way they've danced around the
board from three down to 12 up to six
because i think that
whatever receiver and assuming that the
way it goes is no receiver is taken
through the first five picks and they
have their choice of jaylen waddle of
alabama devonta smith of alabama jamar
chase of lsu
if they have an opportunity to slide
back and dangle the chance to come up
and get a quarterback
uh and and stockpile a pick
and then get one of those three
receivers later let someone else make
the decision for you if you don't know
which of the ones to take so they've
already got two first round picks they
could they could slide back
and and who knows what they could pick
up but chris greer has been a master of
working the board to add pics whether
it's through the laramie tunzel trade
these other moves we've seen and and i
think i think
that of all the stuff that's out there
the dolphins
finding a way to slide back and dangling
that pick for someone who can come get a
quarterback that's the one that
resonates the most with me charade
yeah that's not gonna surprise me either
mike the way they've moved around
already in the way that that they like
to move around so yeah that would be
very possible especially as you said if
those three receivers are sitting there
what if kyle pitts is there too they can
move back and still get one of those
playmakers for that offense and make to
a very very happy regardless and and
still pick up some more picks over the
next two years this is another team
young quarterback young coach they're
not going anywhere for a while they have
time to build this roster and they're
doing that with all the draft picks
they're stockpiling
all right the the rams and i
they have a draft house this year i i
guess they needed to build something
with stan cronkies money that's nicer
than where sean mcvay was last year for
the virtual draft but
if you haven't seen it it looks pretty
nice shireen the rams malibu draft house
is what
well it's the first of many sponsorships
i think that we're going to see it
rocket mortgage is the one that's
sponsoring this right so we're going to
hear all about rocket mortgage every
time the rams pick a player they've
sponsored this house but i think it's a
challenge to cliff kingsbury come up
with something better although i still
like cliffs it's awfully good and jerry
out on the yacht was pretty good too
mike
sofi is a personal finance company so it
doesn't really conflict with rocket
mortgage that was my first thing you're
talking about entities that like to loan
money
you may get one of your sponsors upset
about the malibu draft house sponsored
by rocket mortgage but so far different
enough that that won't be an issue hey i
say it's going to be empty the first
night because they don't have it they
don't have a first round pick what do
they need a draft house for i guess they
need to just need a place to hang out
and watch the draft for the first night
because they don't have anything to do
there's no way in hell they're trading
into round one they just sit back and
and
you don't even have to watch it just
tell us the 32 guys that we're taking
and we'll plan our board for the next
day so uh they're going to hang out
probably have a few beers and enjoy the
draft on a giant tv sponsored by rocket
mortgage all right the nfl equivalent of
this european super soccer league which
apparently is dead before it even got
off the ground the nfl equivalent of it
is what shireen
well it's been a pr disaster so it's the
houston texans right because they're a
star disaster
has kind of fallen apart
over the last year so i was ready to say
the nfc west and then when this thing
started falling apart i was like man
this sounds just like the houston texans
the way their years gone
they could have hired jack east to be to
be the commissioner of the super league
uh
probably would have been the best news
for the houston texans in a long time
yeah i i think the nfl equivalent is is
there isn't one because the nfl
uh already is an american league it's
not like we're gathering up teams from
different countries but but as i wrote
today and i mentioned this yesterday on
rich eisen's show
if the broadcast antitrust exemption
ever goes away and teams cut their own
tv deals shireen the cowboys if they're
cutting their own deal and other teams
that i don't need to name teams not
nearly as popular as the cowboys are
cutting their own tv deals the disparity
in revenue and the willingness of teams
to share that revenue
that could set the stage for a
fracturing of the nfl it would take
something like that that could split the
nfl into the ultra popular national
teams and maybe you could do a
relegation thing based upon value of tv
contract i don't know but it would be
something like that before it could
happen but but
there definitely are disparities between
the best and the worst teams in the nfl
the most popular teams and the least
popular teams in the nfl and if that
ever got exploited financially that is
when the nfl would have a potential
problem holding it all together
yeah and mike when you look at the nfc
east that's another thing you could have
thrown in here about being the supe
super league if you're talking about
money it would be the nfc east right for
the top nine teams in the forbes list
are from the nfc east i mean those teams
make mega money there's a reason when
the cowboys joined the nfl in 1960 1959
actually 1960 was their first year but
when they joined into the nfl as an
expansion team they wanted to play in
the nfc east and they held it up until
they got their way to play in the nfc
and that was the reason why because they
have all those big markets that they
play twice a year mike
and uh look
as
rich people make more and more money
those of us who aren't billionaires
can't really understand this but the
thing that makes you a billionaire
makes you keep pushing for more you
don't just pull the plug one day and say
i'm just gonna go do nothing for the
rest of my life
you keep pushing and pushing and pushing
that that's where this super league came
from more ways to generate revenue more
ways to make more money more ways to get
more and his gambling pumps more money
into the sport that that and it's great
it's raw greed capitalism greed it's the
same thing it's just different numbers
of letters in the word and it pushes for
more and more and more and that
that sharing of tv revenue
i think has always been more tenuous
than they would let on if that would
ever pop that's the thing that could
blow the lead of the league apart the
teams would still exist they would just
be in different universes different
worlds and different stratospheres of
how much money they make
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports